nos piden elegir la gráfica de la
función que se muestra aquí las
funciones f x igualados por 3 a la equis
y aquí nos dan tres opciones como
siempre los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y vean si pueden determinar cuál
de estas opciones corresponde a la
gráfica de fx resolvamos esto juntos
aquí tengo una función que es una
función exponencial ya que tengo un
número que estoy multiplicando por otro
número y este otro número está elevado a
una potencia lo que me dice que estamos
trabajando con una función exponencial
me gusta pensar en dos cosas una es cuál
es el valor de nuestra función cuando x
es igual a 0 al ver esta función esto es
igual a dos por tres a la cero y esto es
igual a tres a la cero es 1 2 por 1 es
igual a 2 así que una forma de pensar en
esto es decir que la gráfica de igual a
efe x cuando x es igual a 0 lleva a ser
igual a 2 otra forma de pensar en ello
es ver este valor en una función
exponencial que a veces se le llama el
valor inicial
la intersección con ya va a estar
descrita por este valor cuando tenemos
una función con esta forma lo vimos aquí
cuando x es igual a 0 3 a la 0 fue 1 y
se multiplicó por este 2 que nos dio
igual a 2 cuál de estas gráficas tiene
un valor en igualados en la primera la
intersección con jane es igual a 1 en la
segunda gráfica parece que ya tiene un
valor de 3 y en la tercera gráfica que
tiene un valor de 2 y simplemente por
eliminación en este caso podemos estar
bastante seguros de que esta tercera
gráfica es la que nos piden es la
gráfica de esta función pero sigamos
analizando la para seguir probando
nuestras habilidades para trabajar con
cualquier función exponencial que nos
pongan enfrente la segunda cosa que
debemos darnos cuenta es que este 3
comúnmente se le denomina la proporción
común y esto es porque cada vez que
incrementamos el valor de x en 1
elevaremos este 3 a una potencia mayor o
esencialmente multiplicaremos por 3
otras
por ejemplo efe de uno va a ser igual a
dos por tres a la uno o dos por tres que
es igual a seis así que de efe de cero a
efe de uno esencialmente multiplicamos
por tres y seguimos multiplicando por
tres
efe de dos va a ser igual a dos por tres
al cuadrado que es igual a 18 que es lo
mismo que multiplicar 6 por 3 así que
nuevamente cuando incrementamos nuestra
x en 1 multiplicaremos el valor de la
función por 3 ahora veamos cuál de estas
gráficas hace esto es te dijimos que
tiene la intersección en equivocada
sin embargo qué hace cuando pasamos de x
igual a 0 a x igual a 1 nuestra que pasa
de 1 a 3 y cuando pasamos de 3 a casi 9
parece aquí pareciera que esto si
tuviera una proporción común de 3 aunque
tiene una intersección en diferente de
la función que nos interesa
parece que la función de esta gráfica es
simplemente 1 x 3
aquí comenzamos en 3 y cuando x es igual
a 1 parece que no está allí es igual al
doble del valor anterior y parece que
sigue haciéndolo cada vez que x se
incrementa en 1 parece que la gráfica de
esta función es igual a cuando x es
igual a 0 nuestra y es igual a 3 3 es
nuestro valor inicial y si duplicamos
esto cada vez pues esto se va a
multiplicar por 2 a la x la función de
esta primera gráfica parece que es igual
a 1 por 3 a la x
o simplemente igual a 3 a la equis y la
tercera más vale que funcione ya que es
la que elegimos como la opción correcta
veamos si estamos en lo correcto cuando
es igual a 1 así que conforme
incrementamos en 1 nuestra ye se
multiplica por tres así que dos por tres
en efecto es igual a seis y cuando
nuestra x aumenta en uno nuestra ya
debería ser igual a 18 pero ya se sale
el valor de la gráfica pero parece
razonable que estamos multiplicando por
3 cada vez y también podemos hacer lo
opuesto si incrementamos el valor de x
en 1 deberíamos dividir esto en 32
dividido entre 3 parece muy cercano a
este valor de aquí dos tercios así que
en efecto nuestra tercera opción es la
correcta